oh my god
it's become a familiar sight but not at
this time of year
wildfires lighting up the sky in the u.s
state of colorado
and while previous fires in the region
happened in rural areas this latest
blaze hit suburban areas near denver
hundreds of homes have been destroyed
and tens of thousands of people are
being evacuated
but thick smoke has reduced visibility
hampering rescue efforts
you know this is the first time i've
really been involved in anything like
this and i'll tell you it is really
scary the the ditches and things and the
trees oh they're all up in flames like
there's embers everywhere so it makes me
very frightened of course with the wind
that it's going to
continue to
spread to other homes
authorities say at least some of the
wildfires were started by falling power
lines
but powerful winds whipped flames and
smoke into a frenzy causing the fires to
jump and spread
there's neighborhoods where because of
the
nature of the fire spread by gusts of up
to 105 miles an hour
it would spread to a house here or there
over other houses past other streets a
very unusual
burn pattern and the other unusual
factor is just as in in the blink of an
eye
this was a
disaster
in in fast motion
uh all over the course of half a day uh
nearly all the damage many families
having
minutes
minutes to get whatever they could their
their pets their kids into the car
uh and leave
this area of colorado in the foothills
of the rocky mountains is more used to
snow at this time of year
but the region has suffered drought for
months and has had little rainfall since
summer the snow is now predicted but
scientists say with more extreme weather
brought on by climate change
wildfires are becoming more and more
destructive
milano vaseline rich sky news